a su llegada a beirut el secretario
general de las naciones unidas antonio
guterres afirmó que la comunidad
internacional no había apoyado lo
suficiente a líbano un país que sigue
luchando contra una economía paralizada
múltiples crisis políticas y las
consecuencias de la devastadora
explosión del puerto el año pasado
durante su reunión con el presidente
michel aún el secretario general también
arremetió contra los propios políticos
del país viendo el sufrimiento del
pueblo del líbano los líderes políticos
libaneses no tienen derecho a estar
divididos y a paralizar el país
instó a los políticos del país a
trabajar juntos para resolver esta
crisis
y pido a la comunidad internacional que
refuerce su apoyo a líbano eats o por tu
lado no se calcula que alrededor del 80%
de la población libanesa vive por debajo
del umbral de la pobreza el presidente
libanés dijo que sus funcionarios
estaban trabajando con el fondo
monetario internacional para reactivar
la economía y aseguró que las elecciones
se celebrarían a principios del próximo
año he confirmado a su excelencia la
celebración de elecciones parlamentarias
la próxima primavera que queremos que
sean transparentes para reflejar el
deseo real de los libaneses
de elegir a sus representantes
debido a las luchas internas el gabinete
no se ha reunido desde mediados de
octubre con especial discordia sobre el
juez encargado de investigar la
explosión del puerto de beirut en 2020
un puerto que antonio guterres visitará
para rendir homenaje a las 215 víctimas
de la catástrofe antes de partir en
miércoles